à l'entrée de val d'or en bordure de la
117 deux grandes mains jointes des
fleurs et une croix c'est à cet endroit
que l'on a retrouvée en 2003 le corps
d'une jeune femme autochtone jeanne
ipouck haschich est morte assassinée le
jour de ses vingt ans cette photo d'elle
a été prise quelques heures avant le
drame tel retour d'octobre des femmes
des enfants viennent se recueillir ici
ils sont là aussi pour cindy libertas
nangon quine de 44 ans dont on est sans
nouvelles depuis le printemps 2014
une autre disparus parmi tant de
disparus au canada
notre enquête a débuté avec cette
disparition qui n'a jamais fait les
manchettes et qui tranquillement sombrer
dans l'oubli
ses ouailles lorsque nous avons
rencontré les parents de cindy libertas
et se sentait seul et laissé pour compte
vous n'êtes pas tenu tellement pouvoir
et ce qui se passe
lafleur mon chapeau on lui connaît pas
les inquiéter mais bon les enquêteurs se
sont pourvus ce point policy qui venait
heurter les premiers visiteurs nous
lâcher vos jours à val d'or nous avons
aussi recueilli les témoignages très
troublant de femmes autochtones
si le fameux chalet de ski de fond la
route de l'aéroport où les policiers
seront faire des pipes par des savants
d'octobre
ceci est une rumeur ça ou c'est vrai ces
femmes pour la première fois prennent la
parole et dénonce publiquement le mépris
qu elles subissent de la part de ceux
qui normalement devrait les protéger
moi j'en ai connu
si cet agent de la sq que ceux qui lui
demandaient faire deux fellations et
cet agent d'un du culte sommes en
dessous
le général de gaulle quand la bête n'est
même pas s'il reste positif même si je
voyais qu'il avait été passé salut ou ce
qu ensemble demain vestiges du kremlin
cherche bernique j'ai pas la chienne de
police mais je leur faut qu'ils arrêtent
de faire du mal au fait qu'est ce qui se
passe en ce moment c'est gable la peur
et la méfiance envers les policiers font
partie du quotidien de ces femmes qui
portent plainte contre la police
je suppose qu'ils vont faire les
policiers à j'ai jamais entendu parler
de ce jeu jamais rien attendu
je suis partagé entre zones jaunes ça
que ça arrête
je dis pas pour mes filles une petite
fibre
je suis cramé manque aujourd'hui
cette absence j'ai pas
aussi les photos de cette dupouy une
belle chimie bons termes mêmes de temps
molle
emilie nous montre ces photos d'enfants
avec ses couettes à dos de cheval en
famille rien ne peut laisser présager
qu'un jour la petite cindy joindra les
rangs de toutes ces femmes autochtones
portées disparues au canada les bourses
ou venu de regarder ses parents johnny
et emilie ont parcouru sans relâche des
milliers de kilomètres du nord au sud
pour tenter de la retrouver
j'en ai fait beaucoup montcourt beau
concours
mais la jda
c'est avec l'éviction de vivre ici
moment l'hôte de chercher chercher
des fois je métaux
à l'âge adulte la vie de cindy dérape
alcool drogue prostitution violence
conjugale
malgré les tempêtes elle demeure
toujours en contact avec sa famille lui
avait parlé à cindy c'est elle qui vous
a appelé pleurer au téléphone m'a
demandé de deux possibles argent en gros
100 j'ai dit non ses pattes par sodium
puis le jeu vous ne voulez l'été sinon
pile c'est la dernière fois je lui
parlais après ce que j'ai dit et bien
dit je te rappeler plus tant il m'a
jamais rappelé les semaines passent puis
l'été sans que sa famille s'inquiète
vraiment mais au début de l'automne ses
parents apprennent que cindy n'a pas été
vue depuis le mois d'avril
n'est pas tout seul on peut y disparaît
mais en a fait le parquet allait voler
police
la sûreté du québec amos a ouvert une
enquête mais rapidement le dossier a été
transféré à rouyn noranda puis au bureau
des enquêteurs du quartier général de la
sqda montréal lors de notre passage en
avril
la famille était sans nouvelles des
enquêteurs depuis plusieurs mois face au
silence des policiers emilie gianni
décident de mener leur propre enquête
il faut imprimer 250 photos de leur
fille qu'il distribue au québec et en
ontario
j'ai tellement aimé son coup c'est le
lait des sommes pour tout l'été la fois
mais sommes pas
à une centaine de kilomètres de la
communauté de pikogan en abitibi où
vivent les parents de cindy se trouve le
camp familial
la famille s'est réunie pour tenter de
retrouver une certaine quiétude au
contact de la nature
aujourd'hui c'est la fête des mères
jamais oublier m'applique infiniment oui
ça va nous contacter sur facebook a
sauvé nos numéros
quoiqu un appeau niveau normal sa
dernière présence sur facebook
le 13 février 2014 soit deux mois avant
sa disparition
un an plus tard en janvier 2015 ce
message d'une amie tu es rendu ou cindy
une autre information qui entretient le
mystère autour de sa disparition
cindy rhdp rtas venait de recevoir un
chèque de 13 mille dollars de la société
de l'assurance automobile du québec à la
suite d'un accident de voiture un chèque
qui n'a jamais été encaissé
cindy roberta savez une très forte
personnalité son attitude agressive sous
l'effet de l'alcool
faisons en sorte que leurs soeurs ne
passait pas inaperçu au centre ville de
val-d'or que je me dis si ci est en
ville à quelque part que qu'elle a revu
à moi qui souhaitais pas où il est
personne d'important la dernière fois
qu'on l'aurait aperçu c'est le 23 avril
elle s'est présenté à l'urgence de
l'hôpital de val-d'or avec trois pots de
casser elle aurait refusé de porter
plainte contre son agresseur
toutes les personnes à qui nous avons
parlé sont unanimes le conjoint de cindy
rue père tu as était un homme violent
c'est conçu un bac b à ce que je lis la
donne est prévue le 10 le russe jamais
vu de même s'il dit kathy ruth et rtas a
vu les vêtements de sa soeur découpé en
morceaux
j'ai donné des coups de couteau sur ses
neiges fait que ce soit des hommes
la crise aidant elle avait vraiment pas
bien menacé le menacer de quoi qu elle s
en prendre aux autres la famille
c'est à porter plainte
sandra lévesque a travaillé à
l'organisme assaut sexuel secours à
val-d'or que fréquentait parfois celle
des rup et rtas est revenue voir ma
collègue en lui disant qu'elle avait été
bon victimes de violences conjugales
pendant la fête se mêle avec strangulée
elle avait des marques de strangulation
dansant dans son cou puis après son ne
plus jamais revu
nous sommes partis à la recherche de
lits villandry le dernier conjointe de
cindy rue père tu as nous l'avons
finalement retrouver à cette adresse
sur ces messieurs landry si vous nous
aidez nous avons enregistré ce
d'entrevue à son insu était comme un cas
vous n'avez vu ce gros jamais la main
sur elle la fin de la saison mais
obliger la police à chaque fois que les
policiers qui se tramait moustapha ça
mélange mais pendant que vous étiez avec
elle aussi ses sentiments en achetant
déjà plusieurs fois qu'ils viennent à la
sueur
quelques jours après le passage dans
quête à val d'or les policiers de la
sûreté du québec ont perquisitionné le
logement de lits villandry soit plus
d'un an après la disparition de cindy
rue père tu as en octobre 2014 quelques
mois après la disparition de sindh et
libertas caroline tchatcher croit
l'entrevoir dans les rangées d'un
magasin à rayons
elle ne sait pas que cindy est porté
disparu
je les remercie vous fait penser à la
maman tournoi italien la marche normale
moi je regardais ça fait quelques jours
plus tard caroline a rendez vous dans un
organisme pour femmes
elle mentionne à une intervenante
qu'elle a vu cindy auber tasse et
apprend du même coup qu'elle ait disparu
l'intervenant très étonné appelle
immédiatement les policiers sur le coup
la police a pris l'information est
maudit qualifié le tout puis c'est resté
comme ce ton pour le repas à prix ferme
on peut appeler ça près de 3
j'aurais eu l'information que la police
n'aurait jamais été chercher les bandes
vidéo
donc je me demandais comment ça se
faisait que ça n'avait pas été fait
parce que le temps passe et plus je me
dis que si les faces périodiquement les
bandes vidéo mais n'y aurait plus de
preuves de ce il semblait très fortement
qu elle incrédule mentalité remise en
question et que à ce jour il n'avait pas
été volé par une vidéo laisse qu'une ne
s'est pas déplacé elle a plutôt demandé
au propriétaire du magasin de vérifier
lui-même la bande vidéo de faire un
choix d'image et de les montrer à
caroline tchatche et c'est ce que nous a
confié le propriétaire qui n'a pas voulu
donner d'entrevue
et il a ajouté que selon lui toutes les
femmes autochtones se ressemblent les
images qu'il a choisi de montrer à
caroline ne correspondait en rien à la
description qu'elle avait fait
ils m'ont montré une coupe de femmes
mais aucune des femmes mais était comme
mon tournoi
ça peut pas être une autre celle que
vous avez vu qu'une femme autochtone
disent qu'elle a vu une femme autochtone
dans un sac gens comprennent pas son
sérieux qu'on sait très bien que ça fait
six mois qu'on la cherche cette femme le
et plus je comprends pas pourquoi elle
n'a pas pris au sérieux
des fois je me pose la même question
certaines blanche qui était disparue est
ce qu on ajoutera moi je suis un dieu
que je parle de même que des blancs là
il faut tout ou en tout cas s'ils
étaient des maisons à des supporters est
ce que les policiers sont nous vous voir
pour vous parler de cindy n'a personne
non je me passe un peu et vous êtes
toutes ses amies conclut la connaissait
toutes l'ont côtoyé dans la rue comme
cindy elles ont vécu des épisodes de
violence de consommation de grande
vulnérabilité
puis la rencontre a pris une tournure
inattendue entre univers
la police et se sont mises a dénoncé
pour la première fois publiquement le
comportement de certains policiers
charlène pas pâti à parler de sa soeur
qui a été reconduite la nuit très loin
du centre-ville
une pratique douteuse pour permettre aux
femmes en état d'ébriété de dessaouler
en revenant à pied une pratique qui les
rend encore plus vulnérables à la lutte
au sol
souhaitons bon c'est pas le conseil
souhaite ouvrir la semaine l'arrêt ou
pas il fallait qu'ils piquent le boël
tâche il aborde la police citée comme
une escale
je pense pauline policiers vraiment
raciste qu'elle le voyait plus basse de
son parti moi commencent à haïr sortie
du biopic en marchant scrabble en fin de
nuit qu'elle a une marche de quelques
kilomètres puis les histoires
personnelles se sont enchaînés rendus ou
allemagne d'après les mêmes personnes
mêmes patches a argué une telle 2 heures
du matin langella baima débarqué du chat
y apprennent qu'un primat ça que j'avais
deux galettes et évite de biens et primo
cela il a même morceau acheté ma moi
cela dans ma sacoche avec clin d'oeil à
l'année passée il m'a poussé je tombais
à tapie a pris une part de mr les
lâchetés d'abandonner ce qu'ils ont fait
ils m'ont laissé là ils sont partis
les policiers profiterait de ces
endroits isolés priscilla patino conduit
vers l'un d'entre eux à l'extérieur de
la ville
je sais là on s'approche d'eux
je mets du chemin des carrières des
carrières de somme chemin des filets
le monde les demandes il nous amenait
que vous la voix défavorables avec la
police - le chemin qui dans le coin
droit chemin
ça c'est la plupart ce que des films qui
se faisait donc mais des fois ça fait
avec des filles qui s'envenime voix qui
me disait que les balais qui fasse une
pop dans sa lettre qu'ils se fassent par
un complet parleurs la personne les
policiers l'aubaine du fastnet des
clients mais aussi la démarche est tout
sauf pour revenir jusqu'au centre-ville
encore
bien qu'un motion connaissent ce petit
chemin forestier et bien d'autres
endroits aussi se passer des choses
aussi dans cette joie et leur nom à part
la la qu'est-ce que tout ce qui se passe
là bas si vaste et si tu les policiers
voulaient débarquer des faibles mais
cette ruelle et se voit pas par la
bouche ep défi marché 1 ne marchait tout
ça pour avenue dans la ville
ben joue à m embarquer procès il me
parlait de la plage de manu pages de
police ne m'amenez dans un autre endroit
le comici au pyla bassil qui me
demandait plus belles chutes shawa de la
biette les gens qui en avaient dans leur
cas font plus policier
là on arrêtait the world is même donné
un diable moi je pouvais plus
demande un énorme et notre île à berne à
l'aide
tu m'as paris 7e on a été sur le papier
cela
on a le chemin dans bois placé là qui me
demandait de
de fait
une fellation aux autres
il venait souvent bien canaux conduit
ensuite au belvédère un lieu désert la
nuit venue toi est ce que ça te dérange
et ceux qui sont être su exploiter paru
comment te sens-tu d'un mois six mois un
système tellement c'était tellement
j'étais moi aussi ça me faisait rien et
je suis comme j'en avais rien à fouetter
témoin ce que je voulais c'était de
l'argent pour payer la dot sagesse est
pour sa part attendu qu'on veut pas
laisser comme ça
ce n'était pas la seule non je prends la
scène c'était plusieurs
comme je connais plusieurs bas je dirais
pas mal toutes les filles
la piste est surtout ouais sainté les
tatamis
chaque service à mes temps étaient deux
pays chacun 200 pièces de sa place pour
pour le service piste en place que je
ferme ma gueule
des fois on peut encore des femmes
paient en argent des fois c'est les yeux
des femmes à qui nous avons parlé et qui
ont préféré garder l'anonymat nous ont
raconté des expériences semblables
d'abus l'une d'entre elles a voulu
témoigner par écrit ils montrent
identifié m'ont sorti de l'auto et m'ont
baissé les pantalons ils m'ont humilié
j'espère que quelqu'un va agir à leur
endroit parce que ce n'est pas juste
j'en ai déjà assez vécu en grandissant
puis c'était comme être protégé nous
sommes de retour au centre d'amitié
autochtone de val d'or angela king a
hésité longtemps avant de nous parler
la peur est encore très présente est ce
que tu peux nous en parler de ce que tu
veux et tu prends ton temps
un soir la troisième se jeter avec mes
cousins de pillon net en état d'ébriété
puis on avait dit bien dans nos mains le
char de policiers arrêtés puis il ya dix
d'un devis d une une de nos bières puis
d'un parc et d'un chat jean parquet dans
l'auto j'ai appris tout seul il y avait
deux bêtes noires arrivent opposent la
police le pays
le premier patrouilleur est dit mais le
joueur joue à l'ailé terreau givaudan du
poste de police
les monter en haut avec lui oui oui
moment il montre une salle de décoration
il m'a dit ma ses vassaux il m'a dit m'a
surtout la tap ils ne descendent ici
pantalon puis je sois plus précis
enfin je dors descendu à vos pieds c'est
comme si rien n'était c'est clair comme
jour où c'est quoi que c'est quoi que
s'est passé j'ai 20 ans j'avais 19 ans
sans jamais parler d'autres savants non
ça pour la fota pas pourquoi sortir
subit surtout vdb sa ferme et 9,6 par
rapport au politique
c'est pour aider d'autres jeunes aux
autres d'autres jeunes femmes qui vont
peut-être vivre même la même chose je
sais qu'ils vont qui vont nous ramener
en quelque part d'oddo l'ouest au poste
de police le plus comme tu dis toi s'il
amène entre chelle ou quoi que ce soit
ou non qu'ils amènent dans le bois post
au bol d'eau police
le manoir un bar très fréquenté par les
autochtones à val d'or
en fait le seul bar qui les accueillent
d'emblée carole marcil est barmaid c'est
la maîtresse des lieux des confidences l
antenne d intervention policière musclée
à l'endroit de femmes autochtones
elle en a vu et confuse quoi que s'ils
font pas d'aidé s'ils le font parce que
c'est que le policier demande et garonne
en boccia où il venait d'un chemin du
ravin
c'est fait pourquoi ceux-ci ne font pas
des fellations et des blue job en bon
québécois le des bleus au job chiffon
posso ils sont ils sont ils font
massacrer leur réveil d'hekla pide des
bleus dès coups de poing et des brûlures
dans fondateur pe se passe de cette
femme à qui c'est arrivé
non quinze vingts personnes 30 staff et
une violence qui la perturbe beaucoup
sevelen deux jours en parle pas de cette
si belle que je te compte l olaf et il a
aidé l'auteur usé beau boulot
voici les blessures subies par cette
jeune femme nous l'avons rencontré au
manoir
elle nous a raconté comment un policier
de val d'or l'a malmené après qu'elle
soit monté dans sa voiture
elle n'a pas voulu être identifiée mais
elle a écrit ceci il m'a poussé hors de
l'eau tôt lorsque nous étions sur le
chemin de waswanipi vers val d'or il
voulait que je lui fasse une fellation
et j'ai refusé
il m'a poussé en dehors de l'auto et m'a
tiré par les cheveux
il m'a laissé seul sur l'autoroute par
la police n'était pas en uniforme et une
forme elle a reconnu qu'est ce qu'ils
faisaient dans le goulot assouan but
c'est peut-être ce sont son trail de la
muse et des figues ans qui travaille pop
et en plaisir à mon sens qui travaillent
man est long c'est assez lent
carole mars il a hésité longtemps avant
nous parler à visage découvert elle est
si sts pour dire que ce n'est pas tout
les policiers qui agissent de la soirée
lors non j'ai juste pas avoir de touba
que la police faisait pas tout n'est pas
bon il y en a deux trois ou quatre
pommes pourries dingue non
c'est autant et d'autres jeunes filles
qui rentrent ils font la même affaire
qu'on a fait
j'essaye de jazz autre adaptation très
n'ai jamais dit elle ils vont vouloir
tendre ce qu'une fille soit tout seul
faute de quoi il est plus exposé protégé
soit ce qu'ils font non non ce qu'ils
font puisque j'ai entendu aujourd'hui
est extrêmement grave et inacceptable
c'est vraiment groul édith cloutier et
directrice générale du centre d'amitié
autochtone de val d'or depuis 26 ans
elle connaît bien la détresse des femmes
autochtones mais elle a été renversé
parce qu'elle a entendu et par l'ampleur
des témoignages je pensais pas en venant
travailler ce matin que je vivrai autant
d'émotion que si ça se passe ici à val
danger lorsqu'ils soir ça me pèse
vraiment ce qui se passe à vendre en
jeûnant ce qui se passe à toronto
et puis un moment donné mais c'est assez
c'est assez
les abus c'est assez le racisme
porter plainte à la police surmonter sa
peur c'est un défi immense pour une
femme autochtone certaines l'ont fait
mais cette plainte sont restés sans
réponse moi j'ai porté plainte à deux
fois la déontologie policière
prochainement péter brun 2006 déjà cash
terminale j'ai porté plainte service
aussi apporté plein le chirurgien dames
aussi à porter plainte a abouti à rien
ça fait ça va faire dix ans que
j'attends pour sûr que ça bouge pas
beaucoup de porter plainte en
déontologie qui qu'est ce qui est arrivé
quand j'ai porté plainte les idées
qu'elle aime rappeler dans mon seul
larbins calais je l'avais fait avec un
lasso relation sexuelle mais même mais
au terme même pas eu de nouvelles ce qui
a du mal j'appelle d'envoi des fois on
ne peut savoir si ces rues de quoi on ne
veut pas croire une femme autochtone qui
victimes d'abus elle était droguée elle
et alcool et qu'elles étaient
prostituées
maintenant c'est un collectif de femmes
autochtones qui se mobilisent et qui
trouvent le courage d'amener au grand
jour cette série d'abus sénat colère
parce que j'ai par zip c'est là que le
saas ample que c'est comme ça on dirait
qu'ils n'entrent amar ben moi parce que
le sait quelque chose que je voulais pas
sortir parce qu'il y en a beaucoup comme
toi qui ont vécu ce hôpital palier en
cuir je pense à tous et à revivre le
matin vers - puis que moi j'ai j'ai même
pas osé
à mon ex a parlé mais enfin le site a vu
pasqua
c'est lourd à porter
comme toutes les femmes que nous avons
rencontrées cindy perds tu as a
fréquenté le manoir c'est du jamais vu
c'est pas normal qu'une fille qui était
tout à soi piot loue un manoir où ballon
à mai chantal que du jour au lendemain
du paréage et imposer et faire avancer
souvent par les policiers à faire
voiture débat débarqué et ruia 2002 deux
ans et demi de marche ita - 53 nitoo bah
moody désormais les billets sont pas
bijoux d'arles
débarqué du temps
bonjour c'est crise et la chute en route
pour parthenay plus il ya pas pâti est à
montréal est là rendez vous au quartier
général de la sq eu nous sommes le 22
mai soit dix jours à peine après notre
passage au centre d'amitié autochtone je
voulais pas et est allé tirer car la
vente en russie parce qu'ici il ya vingt
ans que je prends confiance
le sonar fais je parle
pourquoi
ce que je vaux
je commence à 21h
là est ce qu a décidé de donner suite à
sa plainte en déontologie dont elle
était sans nouvelles depuis deux ans
l'incident wallemacq parce que je les
plantages me sentir comme j'en ai pleuré
de temps je vais laisser dormir
juste des mois en mois qui appeler
beaucoup de marie tu vois
pour cela elle vient aussi pour dénoncer
une agression sexuelle celui il y a dix
ans et qui impliquerait un policier à la
retraite
nous avons attendu prescillia à sa
sortie du quartier général alors comment
ça s'est passé ça s'est bien passé je
pensais que ça va ça allait prendre plus
totale et marc gicquel vos morts ils
vont rentrer en contact encore pour vous
donner des montres et des photos de
policiers vont me contacter et d'en bas
d'essayer de 2 à 3 semaines kim adjoint
yvon ils vont demander de venir
jusqu'ici c'est encore à montréal
là est ce qu a contacté paix s'il ya
cinq mois plus tard soit en octobre deux
fois elle a annulé sa visite à la
dernière minute
nous l'avons rencontré à val d'or si
vous allez voir les policiers de la sq
une tendre rudy quitter paris
ça va donner une peur bleue vraiment
d'aller pas juste aller parce que je
sais mais ça fera peau neuve
c'est juste avant que la poussière nos
bobos seul
qu'est ce que tu penses qu'il va arriver
sur connu les policiers c'est ça
s'apprécie sa voix est là qu à part ce
qui équivaut à vous protéger après
l'accord quand je vois partout chez ceux
qui vont pas te gère un toucher l'eau
oui une crise de confiance je pense que
quiconque se retrouverait dans des
situations comme ça face à l'autorité
policière qui implique l'autorité
policière
on ne peut pas avoir le sentiment de
confiance devient inexistant
la mère de prescillia a toujours soutenu
sa fille elle aussi est inquiète
puis qui va les protéger elle est autour
de la table quand sa fille et d'autres
femmes ont témoigné des abus qu'elles
ont subi aujourd'hui vous avez ou voir
un plat encore là quelques mois le coup
de sifflet la sq est les filles qui sont
vraiment et ce sont louis sont venus
mais ils vont pas chercher de l'aide 6%
qui sont encore deux sets parce qu'ils
n'ont pas confiance à personne
mozilla mais je voyais à l'air marin
c'est sûr car dsk ce soit je me demande
johnny emilie les parents de ces des rup
et rtas sont à montréal pour participer
à la marche commémorative en hommage aux
femmes autochtones disparues ou
assassinées là est ce qu a relancé
l'enquêté sur ces dires pertes à ce
après semble-t-il avoir appris que nous
enquêtions sur sa disparition et ses
parents ont reçu la visite des
enquêteurs pour la première fois en juin
dernier soit neuf mois après avoir
signalé sa disparition et charmeur
depuis tout l'été parce qu'elle me
disait que mois de novembre au printemps
disait que on attend que la méche fonds
pour campus fait des recherches
là
l'année charles dionne
à rester tout l'hiver à bien valable
j'ai changé j'ai ça me fait souffrir
tout ce que je souhaite retrouver bill
de m
enterré parce qu'il l'a laissé en paix
dans son hangar
aujourd'hui johnny emilie ne sont pas
seuls autour d'eux des gens solidaires
qui les encouragent qui réclame une
enquête nationale sur les femmes
autochtones disparues ou assassinées
déjà 18 mois qui sont sans nouvelles de
leur fille mais la foule leur donne ce
qu'il faut pour continuer ça m'encourage
de popey de l'espoir
la trouvais p
quand vela
ce qui est arrivé moi c'est jean-noël
julien des écuries un habitué
c'est quoi le l'étape le prochain étape
et n'a plus d'étapes on a pu on n'a plus
rien la pole et ça fait longtemps qu'il
nous a pas parlé ne sait plus se
pressent convient et cède nous ont tous
sauf un silence on souffre on est
amusant il faut continuer à vivre
toujours un espoir
et ça arrive pas un cadeau
dans un instant la sûreté du québec
donne sa version des faits le
comportement des policiers des
allégations comme vous mentionnez c'est
ce que la sûreté du québec
l'intérim pour ses comportements
maintenant je crois que vous êtes au
courant de 6 ans à val d'or au poste de
police de vannes quand les abus que des
femmes autochtones disent avoir été
victimes de la part des policiers
vous êtes au courant de son coin de ta
vie l'un est ce qu a été mise au courant
de certains abus dès le lendemain de
notre rencontre avec ces femmes de val
d'or l'impact de cette rencontre dans la
communauté a poussé d'autres femmes
autochtones a rencontré les enquêteurs
quatorze dossiers ont été ouverts pour
des allégations relativement à des
comportements de nos policiers ont
comparé le notamment
de début de pouvoir ou de voie est donc
vous avez identifié pour certaines
personnes effectivement il ya eu huit
policiers qui ont été rencontrés
mais huit policiers dans une petite
ville comme val d'or c'est beaucoup
effectivement c'est plusieurs policiers
c'est beaucoup la vie de policiers une
petite ville s'en prennent comme ça aux
femmes autochtones qu'est-ce que ça
dénote pas ce que ça dit je comprends
que c'est vite pôle sud en poste c'est
seulement qu'ils aident des accusations
ce sont des gars sont inondés accusation
pour le moment tous les dossiers seront
sous contractant des processus des
poursuites criminelles et pénales et à
ce moment là on pourra voir la suite des
choses
huit policiers sur une cinquantaine en
poste à val d'or
ces policiers sont toujours au travail
pour le moment parmi les allégations de
cas d'abus sexuels nous savons que l'une
des victimes et prescillia pas pâti lors
de l'entrevue là est ce qu attendaient
toujours sa venue que la patente qui l'a
malheureusement des victimes n'ont pas
prêté par caen lorsqu'elle sera prête
évidemment elles se rencontrées par les
enquêtes à la direction des normes
professionnelles
la direction des normes professionnelles
ce sont les policiers qui enquêtent sur
les policiers c'est une peau les
enquêteurs disposent de val d'or c'est
vraiment
une idée d' enquête externe qui fait
qu'ils mènent cette enquête l'eau
deux jours après cette entrevue au
bureau de la saq
prescillia a pris son courage à deux
mains et est venu identifier l'un de ses
agresseurs
celui de l'incident du work sa photo est
à l'aube d'une ère que nos digues à ce
sujet du sens plus forte entre saint
plus déterminés
oui parce que j'ai vraiment parlé avec
mon agent puis la famille j'ai commencé
à être ouverte aussi avec avec mon
histoire et savent que ce que j'ai vécu
tu te tout le monde est avec moi je
pense
ce qui m'encourage à continuer ouais
ouais
qu'est ce que tu aurais à dire à des
femmes qui ont peur des représailles la
police son propre monture sont
si tu veux être bien date apport au foot
foot tu parles
ce ne sera jamais bien dans sa peau bien
qu'elle dise avoir réagi très vite à la
situation la sécu n'est pas au courant
de certains comportements de ses agents
mais des femmes qui font des fellations
à des policiers dans des petits chemins
forestiers des femmes qui se font
reconduire loin du centre-ville
mais je vous rassure que les propos que
vous venez de tenir ce ne sont pas des
allégations qui ont été dont nous avons
été informés les pôles si non nous on
n'était pas au courant de ces abus
sexuels là le comportement des policiers
des allégations que vous mentionnez
c'est ce que la sûreté du québec
n'entérine pas ces comportements
nous avons aussi parlé du fait que là
est ce qu avait relancé l'enquète sur 6
bis rue père tu as tout juste après
notre passage à val-d'or
aucun ministre avec notre présence là
bas non pas du tout ici est que les
enquêteurs avaient contacté les parents
de cindy rue berthe as après deux mois
de silence je pourrais pas me prononcer
sur la version des faits mais c'est
évident que lorsque c'est nous qui
subissons cette période avoir perdu un
membre non ça va pas assez vite puis non
les enquêteurs pas cela nous appelle pas
assez souvent ce que des femmes
autochtones en face au sérieux ce que ce
crédible une femme autochtone tout à
fait ce que souhaitez vous me parlez une
femme autochtone ou un dossier de
distancer en octobre pour la sûreté du
québec il n'y a pas de couleur sur aucun
dossier
je compte en touche ont aujourd'hui 12
ans en famille mais le doute persiste et
toutes ces histoires laisse de graves
séquelles au sein de la communauté
autochtone
j'ose dire que pour moi ça me touche
beaucoup beaucoup je vais prendre tout
ce que j'ai comme pour comme influences
que j'ai comme directrice du centre pour
que ce soit pas on aime ce que vous
venez de faire pour que ça tombe pas ce
soit pas juste un autre reportage à la
télé que ce soit pas un nom soit au
calme en écho la télévision c'est pas
aux femmes autochtones offert matelly
plan semble pas dû parce qu'on traite
les femmes autochtones
comme si on était des espaces cancon
n'existait pas une femme autochtone et
une femme blanche se sont égales 6,6 à
madame non
tous nos tombeaux tsonga